well live now to exeter the contenders
to become the next conservative party
leader and prime minister are facing
party members there the second
of 12 hustings for taking place over the
next month before the 5th of september
and we believe that penny mordant is
introducing liz trust here she is of
course she was knocked out in the fifth
round trying to be a
party leader herself
let's hear what she's got to say ladies
and gentlemen the feeling is entirely
mutual
thank you so much
tonight
the fact that so many of you are is
testament to
how every single one of you cares deeply
about the task that's been afforded to
us
this isn't just about one person
it's about all of us
and i know it's not easy
you feel a huge responsibility
i do too
that is the price i'm afraid of
democracy
if we get this decision wrong
we'll shortchange the country
we may lose an election
and everything that we have worked for
will be gone
that's why this matters
so much
why you feel that responsibility and why
i do too and why
i'm here with you this evening
i could have
remained undeclared
i could be off sipping pina coladas
right now but i'm not i'm here with you
because this
this is too important
and i'm i'm not going to leave this to
chance
and nor will you
i came third in this contest
and i owe it
to all of you
to be a signpost not a weathervane
so i've made my choice
and i know it's difficult
because i like both candidates
they are both
good conservatives who love their
country
and they've both done what they thought
was right for the right reasons
i want to say nice things about both of
them
which is probably why i came third
i know that choosing between them is
hard
but this contest is a test
a test that precedes an even greater
test
so who can lead
who can build that team and deliver for
our country
who does have that bold economic plan
that our nation needs
who's got reach who can relate to people
who understands that people need help
with the cost of living now
and who
is going to
rightly clobber our opponents
who is going to hold seats and win back
councils
and who
most embodies
the vision and values the british public
had in their heads and their hearts when
they voted in 2016 and 2019.
at the start of this final phase of the
contest i didn't know the answer to
those questions
but i've seen enough to know
who the person i'm going to put my faith
in is
and that is liz truss
her graft
her authenticity
her determination her ambition for this
country
her consistency and sense of duty she
knows what she believes in
and her resolve
to stand up
against tyranny
and fight for freedom
that's what our country stands for and
that's why i know with her
we can win
and actually
seeing her
over the last few weeks
has made me want to help her
to help her win
to help build the team we need to win
the country
and to give ourselves as a party
and as a nation the pride and the
confidence we need to reach
our full potential
in short folks
to give us all hope
she for me is the hope candidate and
that is why i am here tonight
to be straight with all of you and to
tell you that my choice in this contest
to lead us and our nation
is liz truss
thank you
[Music]